Ngày mẹ tổng vầy, chính phủ mê cô đã liên tiếng phản đối mạnh mẽ kể hoại áp thời bà mức tình trăm,
đối với hàng hoại nhất cầu từ nước này, gió tổng thống mỹ đồn trăm công bố,
mê cô cho rằng đây là hành động đối phương Ví phạm tình thần của hiệp lịch thương mại tự gió bà nước,
mê mê hì cô và cà nader. Tổng thống mê hì cô và cư dià xưa bong đã chilt tập học cần và tuyên bố sẽ sử dụng mọi công phát liếc,
kể cả cơ chế giả quý tránh chấp để bảo hệ lợi của ra,
phía mê cô cạnh bảo mức thêm mới sẹ gây tổn hành nghiêm trọng cho trôi cù ở móc mấy,
đó bia trọng các ngàn cộng nghiệp phụ trợ và lập giáp ổ tổng,
hai bên đã tổ chất của họ cấp cao tại Washington,
người mùa thống bây và nhất chỉ thành lập nhóm cục tá sống phương,
nhằm tìm giả pháp thay thế cho hạt của bộ thẳng đám,
trước đó, tổng thống mỹ đồn trăm tình bố mức thị bà mề phân trăm,
áp dụng tròn khác, nông, nông sản và linh kẹt cộng nghiệp,
nhằm bối phó của khủng hảm mát truy về tà nên,
nhưng đẹg ngọt hả năng giảm tình,
nếu mấy hí cô hợp tá kìm xóa mát truy y vàng gọi nhập cơ,
các chuyên gia cạnh bảo chân chấp nếu kéo dài,
có thể anh hưởng đến đầu tư và tạng trở phía tế của mấy cô,
dự kiến trong thử giáp tởi,
hành lối sẻ nổi lạc đối thoại cấp cao để thảo gốc càng thẳng
và rưỡi chì hợp tá chồng các lịch vực thành chốt,
như anh ninh, zi cơ và mũ tròn.